one of the ways to say safe is to spot
the dangers around us on the beach let's
have a look and see what dangers are
around us on planets coast
inflatables are especially dangerous an
offshore wind can blow you out to sea in
no time and it can be very difficult to
get back to shore inflatables are not
designed for the sea the water may seem
calm and gentle but the wind can be
strong enough to take you out to see
very quickly making it hard to get back
jumping in too deep clean water like you
can do it a swim pool is always fun you
can see the bottom and you know how deep
is but if you decide to go swimming
somewhere else make sure it's not a
place like this
now did you see what was wrong with that
let me show you if you can't see the
bottom like here on Margate Harbor harm
then it's really hard to tell how deep
it is or even what nasties might be
lurking beneath anything could have
washed ashore on the last I'd like bikes
or shopping trolleys now you won't want
to jump on these now would you although
the water is clean it is murky from the
sand shifting in the current so you
can't see through it and you have no
idea what is under the water or even how
deep it is now think about this before
you swim in places like this or even
jump in there are other places of
long-vanished coastline where it can be
dangerous to jump into the water margate
Harbor on the pier at viking bay and
ramsgate harbor wall up new places where
you shouldn't jump off into the water
find a nice place to paddle or swim but
not where you have to walk on sharp
uneven slippery walls of the tidal pool
back over to you the only
okay so those are just some of the
places you need to look out for dangers
so what we learnt so far be on the
lookout for marking water times to
shallow water offshore winds and make
sure this thing quite gets out of the
sea